your advice to screenwriters is to get
passionate about
what sells you know we talked about that
earlier so
for them to i think you're the
description for your book you were
saying to
basically they should forget about
comedies is that correct
look comedies are fantastic uh and you
would be correct anyone would be correct
if they said comedies are very high
grossing popular movies they absolutely
are
the problem is the best way for a new
writer to really break into hollywood
and build a career
is to go towards the independent space
not the big studios
there's too much noise at the big studio
level there's way too many barriers so
go to indie hollywood that's where i
work
and that's where really most of the
movies and content that's where it comes
from
so on the comedies front indie hollywood
is not just thinking u.s and canada
we're not thinking our domestic
english-speaking markets we're thinking
global we get a lot of our money from
overseas
and the problem with most newbie writers
is they want to write something like
american pie a really raunchy comedy
or they want to write a very smart
comedy uh
with you know high level humor and and
you know witty dialogue
witty dialogue costs a lot of money to
dub social nuances
in russia or india or japan are not what
they are here
not every country in the world
celebrates thanksgiving and understands
what the super bowl means
there are there are so many subtleties
to the international marketplace
that even if you nail your comedy script
and make it wide enough for an
english-speaking audience to understand
that's a very limited part of the world
and the way a hollywood executive
or the way a producer will read that is
that's a very limited
cross-section of money and i'm missing
out on a lot of other revenue that can
come in
so comedies are great just keep them in
your back pocket
so i'm taking from your the amazon link
for your book
writing for the green light how to make
your script the one hollywood notices
which is out in march it's out in march
great okay congratulations thank you
um and so you say that instead you would
encourage them to write
family films with kid heroes action
films
for aging male stars and female driven
thrillers yes those are three of what i
call the gold mine genres yes
yes and and one thing i noticed is sort
of the socio-economic levels of all of
these films when you say like a woman in
peril
it's never in a bad apartment it's
always in a really nice place so
it seems like a lot of these there has
to be a certain almost standard of
living
people don't want to see i mean just
just from what
you see sells nothing personal or
someone's certain taste but
it has to be almost this upper middle
class yes family
and and even if it's a murder mystery or
something that always has to be that
level
why that's so fascinating that's where
the biggest
cross-section of the purchasing
marketplace is
in this country and throughout the world
um that's where
uh advertise advertisers are are seeking
to get their
uh you know advertisements in front of
that audience uh that makes sense
yes that's if that's who's buying things
right exactly but why wouldn't they
wanna see
they wanna see people of their own thing
in a story they want to see someone at
their level of their sort of
social strategy or their idealized level
yes ah okay interesting
yes i mean movies and television it's
fantasy we all wanna
we watch it because we identify with
these characters but
but they are living out something that
we're not uh they're experiencing
something we don't get to
uh for the female driven thrillers i
mean a lot of female driven thrillers
actually answer
questions that are more fantasy what if
i had you know
been with that guy what if i had made
that decision instead and they sort of
answer what could have happened in those
scenarios
um the tween films those are those are
fantasies for younger kids where they
get to go live this big adventure
you know and the the male action star
they're just fun
but they really speak to male audiences
because it's the ultimate you know alpha
male
doing all the things it's the delta
force hero uh that secretly works on a
farm in the middle of nebraska or
something like it speaks to middle
america and speaks to a big cross
section of the world
and a screenwriter trying to make films
for an overseas audience what should
they keep in mind let's suppose they
realize that
a large portion of revenue is coming
from overseas should they start
try to target stories and make them more
i'm not sure what your phrasing is of it
but more ethnic
or keep it still very americanized it's
okay to be americanized
um it's okay to be very true to i mean
whatever country
you live in and are writing screenplays
for you know if you're living in england
and want to write screenplays for the
american market or anything
but i think the biggest trick for a
newbie writer
is not to assume they understand how the
international marketplace
works because that changes all the time
so the best way to get ahead of it is
basically just stay neutral keep themes
very universal and then whenever it
comes to a very specific
targeted element like thanksgiving
american football you know some
colloquialism
um always see if there's a way to
replace it
maybe maybe switch out american football
with soccer maybe instead of
thanksgiving
make it christmas that way it's a little
bit
more balanced and the world can identify
with it but at the same time i mean you
know i think
most screenwriters are also just avid
film fans and i love a foreign film as
much as the next person so
if i'm watching a movie as long as it's
true to that country
and i understand the themes behind it i
accept it and american content does
travel the world the best
you